well we've certainly brought in a lot of
different measures the army coming in to
familiarize themselves with the
distribution is the 18th separate
measure we've taken and of course a lot
of petrol's now being transferred into
people's cars
and there i are now the first very
tentative signs of stabilization in the
four court storage which won't be
reflected in the queues as yet uh but
it's the first time we've seen uh more
petrol uh in the petrol stations uh
itself
i think as the industry said yesterday
um the sooner we can all return to our
normal buying habits um the sooner the
situation will return to normal and uh
and we all need to to play our part and
certainly don't do things like bring
water bottles to petrol stations it's
it's dangerous and extremely unhelpful
uh you announced yesterday that the the
army were going to be put on standby um
isn't this a little bit late given that
you're already suggesting that you're
seeing the sort of green shoots of
things getting better that you've wasted
too long to to make that step
well there's a series of escalations
that uh that you go through with a
crisis like this and we've already put
18 different steps in place which i i
should say stretch right the way back to
the spring remembering that this problem
is almost entirely caused by coronavirus
and the inability during lockdowns to
test new hgv drivers so we lost 30 000
hgv drivers through that process so
since april we put in numerous different
measures 18 in total with the 18th being
the army being put on standby and
they're familiarizing themselves with
the distribution system
but primarily as we all return to our
normal buying habits and as we're now
starting to see with so much petrol
transferred to car tanks in the last few
days there's nowhere else for that
petrol to go and we're starting to see
very tentative signs of stabilization of
the amount of fuel under the forecourt
though that won't yet reflect itself in
queues but will start to reflect itself
over the coming days and fewer stations
being closed
the fact that you've taken 18 steps and
now escalated it to the point of
introducing the army doesn't that
suggest that the public don't trust you
that you've had to get to this stage to
try and reassure them
i think it's important to know that
coronavirus has created a shortage of
lorry drivers tanker drivers throughout
the world and you know for example in
poland there's 123 000 um shortage
germany 60 000 shortage america and says
the worst crisis they've ever had it's
impacting on everyone the system was
just about coping up until uh last
weekend and it would have been capable
of continuing to do so unfortunately
as we've seen with toilet rolls and
other things once people start to pursue
a particular
item it can quickly escalate but the uh
say there's only so much petrol you can
transfer into tanks
that is starting to
work its way through do appeal to
everyone
once we all return to our normal buying
habits and stop trying to top up
our vehicles certainly don't bring you
know plastic water bottles to fill up
it's unhelpful it's dangerous the sooner
that happens the quicker we get back to
normality and there's tentative
stabilization the amount of stock in
four courts is the first sign that that
may be starting to happen though it
won't yet be reflected in queues
last question on fuel
you suggested the fact that there are
there are shortages across europe there
are suggested there are shortages in
drivers in america
none of these countries are having the
same level of effect that it is in the
uk why is that the case if this is
nothing to do with brexit or drivers
leaving everyone's experienced a
pandemic everybody already has existing
shortfalls why is it the uk is
experiencing this more than other
countries
well coronavirus has certainly created a
big shortage we weren't able to test 30
000 lorry drivers and that's had a an
impact the system was uh coping and uh
the difficulty with any of these things
uh is as soon as somebody gets an idea
for example bypasser at the beginning of
the corona virus and then that turns
into a stampede uh there's almost
nothing you can do with the supply
system to prevent it having said that
there's only a finite amount of space in
fuel tanks we've taken 18 different
steps of which uh prepping the army is
the latest and we're starting to see
just the first signs of stabilization uh
which won't yet be uh reflected in the
queues but is in the percentage of fuel
uh now available in the underground
storage in uh the actual uh petrol
stations itself um so this reflects
itself in different ways in in different
markets brexit i here mentioned a lot
and it no doubt will have been a factor
on the other hand it's actually helped
us to change rules to be able to test
more drivers more quickly flexibilities
that we've uh received by coming outside
of the eu and being able to change the
law so it's it's actually worked in in
both ways the sooner we all return to
our normal buying habits uh the quicker
this gets resolved and i you know do
appeal to the public to do that in
particular you know no more water
bottles petrol stations it's dangerous
and unhelpful